normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Matt
Walsh has taken off the glove and struck
me with it in his latest episode he said
Tim poool is wrong how dare you so no
I'm just kidding uh I respect Matt wal's
opinion I love the debate and Matt Walsh
says the budlight boycott
continues in a tweet he he also did have
a a decently long segment on his show
where he addressed Dana White tuck
across and kid as well as myself and uh
it was respectful and it was uh
intelligent and I agree with a lot of a
lot of what he said and I don't
completely disagree with the idea of
continuing the boycott all I'm saying is
we need to consider our next moves if
the plan is a boycott but let me read
first what Matt Walsh says he tweets the
Bud Light boycott is one of the is is
the one time in modern history when
conservatives have staged an effective
boycott against a major corporate brand
if we back away from this Victory now it
will show that we've learned nothing and
don't want to win not going to happen
boycott continues this shouldn't even be
a conversation budlight is a brand owned
by a foreign conglomerate that tried to
push trans ideology and is now paying
the price there is absolutely no
legitimate reason to back away or let
off the gas they deserve everything
that's happened to them well as the
debate continues I'd like to first ask
our local beeran who's here to who
actually runs a beer company and is
challenged budlight directly your
thoughts on on the boycott and what do
you think we should do
I think I've been saying this from the
beginning of this whole thing is like
this is the one time I've seen
conservatives follow through with a
actual boycott in the past we be like oh
we're skipping an NFL game we're
skipping a baseball game we skipped two
or three games everybody's back in the
stands this is the one time we've done
it I think the only way to be taken
seriously in the future is to cause
permanent economic harm to a major
corporation and I think that this is our
opportunity we may fail in the end I
understand what you're saying but this
is our shot to do it and so you have to
stick to it so what's so your your
argument is double down no one should
ever buy budlight again no matter what I
mean it seems a little bias coming from
me I'm not going to lie but yeah what
would be the purpose of doing so at this
point in your life so so my argument
is 30% loss and sales year-over-year up
to date and budlight has just put 100
105 million per year into
UFC now is the opportunity to steal the
narrative with what Shan Strickland said
on Twitter which can't be said on Shan
Strickland's never going to we're never
going to be able to steal the narrative
maybe within a circle narative is stolen
when every conservative repeats what
Sean stri they'll never do it most
conservatives are starts with a P ends
with the Y they don't follow through and
do these things it's never going to
happen me Sean Strickland will and
that's why we're sitting there talking
about Sean strick so consider now where
where we go from here if conservatives
will do nothing else
what what what happens
tomorrow I think they can continue with
their boycott no no no what what does
Bud Light do tomorrow I mean there's a
lot of things they're doing and they're
going to do they're putting more money
into different ones of different brands
within their entity they're doing things
like that where they've pulled back a
lot of the spinning on their advertising
for budlight itself and they've
redirected those F you think budlight
will
apologize no yeah I think an apology
would do more damage at this point no no
I don't think it would think the okay I
I I think an apology would actually
boost sales I think it would remind
people what they did and that would
enhance the boycot people haven't
forgotten so here's here here's here's
the paths we have before us if everybody
wants to continue the boycott I'm
totally on board we need people to
Double Down yes Sean Strickland opened
the door for you I'm not saying what he
does as a UFC champion is the he's it's
it's the tip of the spear but you you're
requiring the rest of the spear for this
to work he made some statement ments on
Twitter directly under the banner of
budl shockingly offensive to the woke
left and budlight said nothing the
attack opportunity right now would be
for conservatives to hold up a Bud Light
repeat the words of Shan Strickland and
say wow thanks budlight for sponsoring
UFC and Shawn we completely agree with
your message and then read off his
tweets the conservatives aren't going to
do it then if they won conservatives
come up to me in the gym and Whisper
like hey I really support what you're
doing I like it I'm like why are we
whispering they're scared you think
they're going to go say the kind of
stuff that why my argument was at this
point with Dana White Kid Rock coming
out and being like we've done we've done
the damage let's claim the victory I'm
like if this is where conservatives stop
and they won't take another step forward
then the best thing we can do right now
is say we won I'm not saying buy Bud
Light ever again fine don't I'm saying
claim the narrative Victory say we've
done everything we wanted to do budlight
learned their lesson and let it be a
lesson to each and every one of you
you've lost 30% good luck in the future
but our message stands I don't think
anyone's ever going to see that as a
victory if they all go back the D I'm
not saying go back I'm saying at this
point you have claim a victory start
claiming it today I'm with you there say
we we've won because it's D you would
have to say we did everything we wanted
to do because if no one goes one step
further and UFC Dana White goes on
Tucker Carlson and says Bud light's
great you should buy Bud Light and no
one calls out Dana White for this and
you have is unscathed then the narrative
is the boycott is over if the boycott is
over Kid Rock said so and Dana White
basically like he's not I think those
are two I think those are two people
I've been bars restaurants stores Etc
the average person is
not my point is how do you get Coca-Cola
how do you get Disney how do you get all
these corporations to be scared to not
do the same thing you have to look at
the fact that bud white will still be
down 25% or 22% 24% whatever it is 3
years from and this requ that a lot of
fear I think it will be there's look
I've talked to Distributors and stuff
there is there is 20 to 23 or something
like this percent that will never go
back to buying Bud Light they bought it
all their lives talk years from now
they'll move it around that's fine but
they will not be able to show within the
Bud white brand because they're treated
like different entities they're not
going to be able to show like oh it came
back it's 22 to whatever it is percent
and 10 years from now they won't have
that leaves a lasting impact on a
corporation that goes like remember what
happened to them that's bad I I I do
think this will have a lasting impact
there's a famous case where uh in
McDonald's in the UK a couple act the
reason why corporations don't Sue
activists a couple of activists were
standing outside outside of McDonald's I
think it was McDonald's petitioning
saying hey McDonald's is bad they do
this thing McDonald's sued them
McDonald's I believe was it's an old
story I could be wrong but I believe
McDonald's was right these activists
were defaming them and they won and then
they lost something like a billion in
market cap because they looked like
bullies attacking some little old ladies
so it was really really bad for them
what ends up happening is when people
challenge Brands the brands usually shut
up and back off well if if oh if you
want to double down if if if the next
move is to twist the knife so to speak
the the proverbial knife you want to
boycott all of the anheiser Bush Brands
which are Michelob Rolling Rock Bush
natural
Johnny and then the question is do you
want to boycott the brands of the parent
company the the Belgian company ABN bed
which are Corona hog Garden if everyone
want boyot every beer brand but
conservative dad's Ultra right beer I'm
with you I don't think it will actually
happen though so that's why I was
specific about with Bud Light I was like
this is the you got to Target in on that
I said that early in and because people
start saying well here's the list of all
the stuff the Nerds are pulling out
their list of all the beer brands you
can't I'm like yeah you got to focus
it's like six to 8% the the the the uh
um ex what's what's the right word the
the the impact on external Brands is
around 6 to 8% we've seen anheiser Bush
across the board suffering because of
this CU some people are Die Hard the
only point I'm trying to make right now
what's the next move silence is not an
option I think what needs to happen is
by all means say we boycotted it we'll
boycott it forever but it's done we're
moving on we've won this is this is your
fault Bud Light and it'll happen to any
other company that does so next but you
need to say this is the extent to which
we wanted right that's fine TOA I get
what you're saying there that's fine to
claim the truth there but you can't say
it's okay to come back now like Dana
White can tell people to do keg stands
in their in their garage every day I
agree and I I like probably a ton of
what Dana White does not a big fan of
that because you know what who knows
what you could get me to say for 105
million so Dana there you go I think
we're also in a position of power right
now and in in a situation like like this
they understand the the leftist yuppies
are not going to be drinking their beer
right so why not try to get more out of
this and I think we can get kind of more
out of this by by saying hey uh we can't
just be plated with a little bit of
money we want real cultural differences
we want investment we want you guys to
actually stand behind your word not just
advertise we want more white can be
plated by a little bit of money or maybe
a lot of money per se Al then you know
what if they want to give 105 million to
the rally gain Center to Def to fight
men and women sports then I say big
victory how much how much are you going
to give to the Republicans how much are
you going to give to the Republic
Nom the culture War we just won a huge
battle the troops are broken they are
fleeing now is our opportunity to to do
the route but they're sending a rear
guard attachment to delay our route
that's the 100 million to Dana White is
the rear guard defense now we can bypass
that defense and go for the route by
boycotting all of these beers from this
company that's it that's the total
destroy destroy what do you want respect
I respect the the the analogy but I
think it's a little off the giving money
is they've been routed their command
their their field command commers raised
the white flag and said we're willing to
seed 10% of the battlefield if you stop
and then one of the commanders on our
side came out and said everyone let's
take it and we're done and many many all
the troops are screaming no if that's
the case you cannot just sit there
screaming no something else must be done
the opportunity now I think is going to
be uh the figurative knife twisting of
taking a can of Bud Light and reading
off Shan Strickland's tweets and forcing
Bud Light to either issue a denouncement
or an apology like look all I can say is
this people really need to go go read
what Sean stricklin said to understand
what I'm saying I can't I cannot say it
I I cannot say it on YouTube I know but
it's just a tweet no one's going to it
doesn't have that kind of influence you
there was a guy who lost his sponsors in
NASCAR because his dad used a racial
slurt in the 80s that's where we were
where we are now is that Bud Light shut
up up when Sean Strickland made a
statement so so so strong we I can't I
can't repeat it on YouTube that and no
and nothing nothing happened so This Is
Us storing the battle really reached the
average person knowing about that this
is why I'm saying people need to take
his tweets and and force budlight to
either support or denounce what he said
budlight advertisement with with him
with the dag saying it to the world I
don't understand why guys AR interested
in boy sponsored by Bud Light he said
brought to you by Bud Light like Bud
light's just a name of the of many
things that the company why not boycott
the entire company all these you are
correct no one's doing
it look how hard it was to get
conservatives to boycott anything past a
couple days and now you're going to tell
them they got to read a list of all
their favorite alcohol Brands and they
can't get a Corona on the beach anymore
they can't handle it okay we can't get
Republicans to show up and freaking vote
in a freaking primary and you're asking
we give her their favorite beer we went
to Charleston West Virginia it's about
five hours from here we went to Marty gr
Casino where several people recognized
me and they were big fans and they were
all holding Bud
Lights and I laughed and I was like you
guys drinking Bud Light and they're like
well I don't
know my boy this is the funny thing
right we launched uh uh we relaunched
cnr.com and I got a Super Chat the other
day from someone like what is this
you're just going to launch this thing
with no explanation and I was like bro
we've explained this like 20 times over
the past two months the issue is the
average person doesn't watch every
single episode of this show so how often
do we talk about Bud Light out of how
many segments we do we do five to six
segments per day on this show that get
spread out throughout the week and over
the past six months maybe like 20 of
them maybe 30 have been about but we
haven't talked about it in like three
months exactly I think that's when I was
here yes Aus we talk a lot of people
don't know this my view is simply we we
want
every company to say I don't want to go
near Dylan mulvania and woke woke
sponsorship because I will lose lots and
lots of money how so then that that
would mean we need to say we did it we
won B Bud Light bye-bye and then we just
move on from
it that might be the right move I don't
hate ab and Bev I mean they made a
stupid Choice by marketing their beer to
kids with through through Dylan malany
and maybe that's all that needs to be
known like don't do it again it's you
know I'm not huge fan of multinational
corporations but there's other ones like
the bank for international settlements
that I'd rather be boycotting yeah look
all major corporations I say all the
vast majority of major corporations hate
every single one of us in this room and
everything we stand for and they give
tons of money to those causes that we
hate go ahead I think they hate
everybody I think most corporations are
looking at numbers and they're thinking
where do how how do we get sales my
concern is with a company as large as AB
inbev if sales among conservatives has
gone to zero they are not going to stop
trying to market the beer but it hasn't
gone to zero there are still a huge
percentage of conservatives that are
still drinking it absolutely as I
mentioned so they've got to right so
they they've got to have that fear of
okay we can't do anything else or we
will really be toast I don't believe
conservatives drink more beer than
liberals by the way I I I I I believe
that's true and that's why they screwed
up because budlight that that woman was
like the Frat bro image like well who do
you think is drinking your beer you know
what I mean if if a liberal drinking a
beer it's going to be some weird small
batch you know craft brew out of
Williamsburg or something holla my my
concern is putting $100 million in UFC
is an opportunity to say spend money on
us give us your money someone super
chatted that Dana White just got a $100
million for free to make fun of Bud
Light yes we want more of that how can
we get more of that what we don't want
is for budlight to eventually come April
go we spent $100 million on this
contract and it's it's given us a zero
return the shareholders are angry and
they're demanding we spend the money
elsewhere then they start investing in
who knows what the same stuff they've
always invested in Liberal causes and
and just advertising in general so right
so we want to stop that we want more
money to go to UFC I think they're in a
situation where they're like their ship
is sinking if their sales are down 24%
that's like a sinking brand agreed but
the UFC has a lot of money the UFC
doesn't
need I don't care if they need it Bud
Light needs the UFC I'd rather Dana
White whether you love them or hate them
have the money over Dylan lania and so
the question is if their ship is sinking
Ian how do convince them that we are the
ones who are going to make their ship
stay upright but they have to give us
the ship oh I just sync the ship just
let the ship syn yeah but it's not going
to well the Bud white brand will maybe
not the overall inbev I get what you're
saying there but Bud Light will never go
away the fleet will not be necessarily
but will forever be a
part right and you agree they'll shift
their spending to other brands correct
and they're going to spend on those
other brands in the same direction they
they they've gone with
budlight no they won't they're not going
to they're not going to do a dill miac
with modella or or Corona whatever but
they'll do Pride events and stuff like
that so does Yingling AB absolutely yep
they do not conservative dad's Ultra
right beer like the only openly pro-life
and as conservative hot women let's just
say this let's just say this the only
option right now is the fight is over we
completely ignore Bud Light never buy
from them again the narrative drops we
don't we don't engage with it we just
support the parallel economy and go to
conservative dad.com and buy your Ultra
right beer that's the option I guess
because then it's not an issue of if
there's a boycott or not it's a we don't
care anymore have a nice day let them
spend the money where they want to spend
it and you spend your money on Parallel
economy products yeah because Public
Square download Public Square I think
that's a good option because it does
feel like going balls to the wall
against AB inbev is like hostile like
unnecessarily hostile I kind of like a
little bit of unnecessary hostility in
my life to be honest though I me way
I've lived the last
I don't know man against a multi I guess
if you're going to go against a
multinational corporation the a beer
Corporation might be the right one to
Target hey fun story so this past
weekend we had our conservative DS Ultra
right uh anti-corporate Retreat up in
Gatlinburg in the Smoky Mountains and
there was evidently a frat party going
on on each side of the cabin that we
were all in so we had everyone with our
company this huge cabin there was a frat
party going on somehow they ended up
with a ton of ultra right beer at these
frat parties I went over there for a
little while were dumping the other
beers they had no Bud Light I'd like to
play it was a fun experience I'm waiting
for those photos and videos to come out
I'll explain it all once it does but it
was a good time had by all well I told
them the other night my victory
condition would be to see your company
buy Bud buy that brand I like this idea
I think we're a few billion short but I
like the concept thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at
timcast.net membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time